this is one of Britain's most
Euroskeptic communities here in Rumford
just to the east of London 70% of people
voted to leave the many of them were
young people after a week of drama at
Westminster what did the under thirties
think now what's the point of leaving is
she's gonna be a lot hustle we want to
breaks it we want a Europe just get a
set I found more of a benefit from
leaving then staying I don't think we
want a brick seat stop arguing
and just get on with it Mumford's young
adults have been following the political
show in London closely the result is
that many are not sure whether leaving
to you it's the right thing to do after
all I was in favor of leaving and when I
voted to leave I I knew that the old
usual term struggles all of the mess
that's going on is has brought me to a
point where I almost regret the decision
to leave 24 year-old Mitchell Omar works
in the technology industry he had
trusted British politicians to deliver
on their promise to secure a good breaks
a deal now he has doubts about whether
that is possible do you see how much of
a mess everything's actually come into
there's no structure and no one knows
where it's going to go there's loads of
uncertainty at the moment I feel like we
should problem we should stay not far
away sue connolly of the local
Conservative Party is just as unhappy
with the draft breaks a deal as Mitchell
Ouma but for her the answer cannot be to
stay in the you I think the withdrawal
agreement has is rubbish basically it's
not what we want it's not what we voted
for we didn't vote for a load of idiots
up in Westminster to hash the whole deal
they've made a total mess of it and you
know that's not the sort of brick seat
we want we will out we want to help now
sue Connelly thinks the young people of
Romford are wrong and doubting beli vote
but back in the snooker club Mitchell
OMA believes that Britain's perhaps
shouldn't have been asked to vote on the
issue in the first place I've only kind
of made the decision like this with
something as complex of Europe has been
put in my hands because being honest I
don't understand it I think the finger
Prime Minister understands it so how are
we making the
this is a thing everyone has an opinion
but no one knows what should happen now
with all the unfolding uncertainty and
chaos comforts young people are not sure
that the brexit game can be one anymore